what color is cyborg blood supposed to
be how many bodies does elita actually
have what exactly are those blue flames
keep watching for the elita battle angel
details only real fans notice
one of the most memorable and exciting
parts of elita battle angel is the high
octane spectacle that is motorball there
are two matches in the film a skirmish
on the streets of iron city and a
professional tryout in a super-sized
stadium despite these two sequences
being decidedly different in terms of
the tone stakes and even the visual
presentation both of them utilize
real-world camera physics even though
the limitations of real-world cameras
don't apply when creating an action
scene with cgi director robert rodriguez
chose to self-impose those limitations
to create a more grounded sequence in an
interview with inverse he described his
methodology for crafting the scene with
a sense of realism as he revealed i
don't want the cameras flying around the
place doing things impossible to shoot i
wanted the physics of real cameras
placement you would see in nascar long
lenses capturing things whizzing by as
well as cameras on the track with the
players to keep it as real world as
possible pulling inspiration from the
shooting style of real world sports and
sticking only to shots that would be
possible with a physical camera
ultimately grounded the bombastic action
with a sense of reality
the character of elita starts out the
film as a total amnesiac while
struggling to recall details from her
past she finds herself stumbling into
some dangerous situations luckily she
possesses an instinctive fighting
technique that kicks in when she's
threatened this combat style is known as
panzer kunst a german term which
translates into english as armor art
panzer kunst comes directly from the
manga series that inspired the film
within the series lore panzer kunst
originated on mars as a martial art
style for use in zero gravity combat in
real life panzerkunst refers to the art
of defeating armored opponents in combat
which is fitting considering that the
majority of combatants in elita are
heavily armored cyborgs the first
descriptions of real-life panzerkunst in
sword fighting are believed to come from
a german fencing manual from the 1440s
this instructional guide offered
insights into fighting techniques to be
used against both armored and unarmored
opponents in a variety of combat
situations though the manual was
primarily focused on fencing there were
also techniques described for other
weaponry and also unarmed combat azaleta
typically dispatches her foes with a
mixture of martial arts abilities and
sword-fighting prowess her fighting
style lines up well with this 15th
century inspiration
after being brought back into
consciousness for the first time in
centuries by dr ido elita is a blank
slate in her quest for self-discovery
she seeks to learn not only who she is
but also what she believes and what she
likes and dislikes when hugo learned
that elita has never tasted chocolate
before he sets about remedying that
immediately so after trying it for the
first time elita declares that she now
has a favorite food
i have a favorite food now
[Music]
this is my favorite food it might look
like a simple chocolate bar but it's
actually a chocolate shell packed with a
honey peanut butter filling and pecans
we know this because it was made by
robert rodriguez himself and he even put
together a tutorial explaining how to
make your own at home he used a 3d
printer to make a custom chocolate mold
in the shape of the zollum symbol found
in the world of elita and he even
brought homemade snacks to the cast of
the film as well throughout his career
rodriguez's love of food has popped up
in his work time and time again as
evidenced by his long-running 10-minute
cooking school series that often appears
in the dvd extras of his movies this has
included making texas barbecue for
planet terror presenting his recipe for
breakfast tacos for sin city and
explaining how to cook puerto pebil for
once upon a time in mexico
long before the elita battle angel film
arrived in theaters the story was first
told in manga form all the way back in
1990. the first run of the manga series
ran for nine volumes that were released
over the course of five years and
multiple sequel series followed in
english this manga is known as battle
angel alita though the original japanese
title translates directly as gun dream
during an interview with bbc radio 1
james cameron described the switch from
battle angel elita to elita battle angel
as a forward-thinking shift with sequels
in mind he suggested such potential
sequel titles as elita fallen angel and
elita avenging angel in the manga and in
the 1993 anime adaptation battle angel
the main character's name wasn't elita
at all but rather galley the name was
changed for the initial english
translation and it stuck around for the
big screen version as well there's
another important difference in elita's
namesake that changed between the manga
and the film in the manga dr ito names
gali after his cat who recently passed
away while the live-action adaptation
ups the ante and has dr ido named alita
after his dead daughter
there are a couple of moments in elita
battle angel when little blue flames
emerge from elita's body though never
explicitly explained in the film they
play an important role later on in the
plot and serve an even more important
purpose in the manga in the manga lore
these little flames are an extension of
alita's ability to manipulate plasma
what might look like a flame is actually
arc plasma these plasma powers
contribute to elita's fighting prowess
by increasing her speed and magnifying
the power of her strikes when she throws
a punch it isn't just a synthetic fist
striking her opponent but also the
destructive power of plasma energy
toward the end of the film when she
finally gets her hands on the much
sought after damascus blade her arc
plasma abilities come into play again
you might notice that the blade turns
blue and glows in her hand something it
never did while in zapan's possession
this is due to her arc plasma powers
surging through the blade and
supercharging it
didn't exactly come with a manual did
you elita battle angel was released in
the united states on february 14 2019
but james cameron bought the film rights
to the manga all the way back in 2000.
he even expressed interest in one day
adapting the story as early as 1995
before the release of titanic he was
ultimately able to buy the adaptation
rights directly from the manga's creator
for the sum of 1 million yen cameron
originally planned on directing the film
himself and he considered going into
production on elita instead of 2009's
avatar of course that didn't end up
happening one key reason for holding off
on alita was that he didn't think cgi
technology was quite ready to deliver
what was needed to do it properly after
the massive financial success and major
technological innovations of avatar
cameron again toyed around with the idea
of directing elita but his attachments
to the avatar sequels made that
impossible enter robert rodriguez a
friend of cameron's for many years who
had seen materials from cameron's
earlier false starts with elita he asked
if the adaptation would ever happen if
cameron was going to be busy with the
avatar franchise for the rest of his
career so cameron then offered rodriguez
the reigns as rodriguez told fandango
all access because we've been looking
for things to work with on together for
years and this was a perfect opportunity
for a collaboration
the blue blood of the cyborgs in elita
might feel reminiscent of other sci-fi
properties such as the inky blue blood
of the androids in 2013's the world's
end but the blood in elita wasn't always
blue in the 1993 anime adaptation battle
angel the cyborg blood was instead a
bright crimson and although the manga
was inked in black and white there was a
clear emphasis on gore that didn't make
it into the 2019 film in an interview
with bbc radio 1 james cameron revealed
that he couldn't be completely faithful
to the manga because of how gory it was
so they softened it for a pg-13 rating
even with this softening elita pushes
the limits of pg-13 as there's plenty of
biomechanical destruction and
dismemberment the mpaa's ratings board
has historically been more lenient when
assigning ratings to films with
unnaturally colored blood so tinting the
cyborg blood blue helped to avoid an r
rating this isn't the first film
directed by robert rodriguez to use
unnaturally colored blood in a bid to
procure a more audience friendly rating
as 1996's from dusk till dawn featured
green blood for the vampires instead of
red that decision was made out of a fear
of receiving an nc-17 which worked out
in the film's favor as it ultimately
secured an r rating alita gets her first
taste of motorball while playing in a
friendly neighborhood skirmish in
contrast to the later stadium motorball
match this first game was intended to be
executed with little to no cgi outside
of the title character this requirement
incurred a number of additional
challenges the first of which was
finding the right talent to fill the
roles of the other players who had to
play this larger-than-life sport as if
it was second nature so stunt
coordinator garrett warren brought
together the world's top professional
inline skaters to execute the scene in a
making of video warren producer john
landau and members of the cast and stunt
team discuss how the unique challenges
of the scene were overcome tall drop-in
ramps and mechanical winches were used
to mimic the speed and momentum achieved
by the motorized rollerblades of the
film which don't exist in real life
the special effects of elita battle
angel exist at the cutting edge of
what's possible with modern filmmaking
technology having a large budget wasn't
all that it took to pull off the
impressive visuals as it also required
the best design team and technology
available rather than scouring the
industry for the best in the business
the necessary resources came from a
little closer to home james cameron had
already assembled the perfect design
team to work on the avatar sequels so
when robert rodriguez got started on
elita cameron lent him the team for a
few months to work out the look feel and
creation of the characters and world the
production also made use of the motion
capture and 3d camera technologies
previously pioneered by cameron for both
the avatar sequels and his documentary
projects cameron wanted a realistic nuts
and bolts look to the cyborgs and the
world while rodriguez pulled from his
experiences as a cartoonist to bring a
lighter sense of style to the film's
look and feel ultimately a happy medium
was found with this design team
the only human part of elita's
physiology is her brain while the rest
of her body is synthetic even her heart
is a pricey centuries-old relic this
means that her body can be swapped out
with different cyborg parts tailored to
specific tasks in the film we see her in
two main cyborg bodies one is a civilian
body initially built in part for dr
ido's daughter before her death while
the other is a reclaimed berserker body
built for combat there are also a few
quick glimpses at another cyborg body in
flashbacks warrior's spirit needs a
warrior's body
however in the manga and anime alita has
even more cyborg bodies that she can
switch between that are best suited to
particular activities before the
motorball match in the film dr ito
insists that alita wear protective pads
on top of her berserker body but in the
manga lore alita has a specialized body
made just for motorball this motorball
body has less destructive capabilities
than her berserker body but it's much
faster and more flexible if elita battle
angel ever winds up getting a sequel
there's a chance we might see more of
her specialized cyborg bodies
[Applause]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you